social media giant facebook and its
instagram and whatsapp services have
been hit by widespread outages facebook
says it's aware some people are having
trouble accessing the platforms but
hasn't said what's behind the problem
well let's speak to ian share about this
he's the editor at large at the consumer
tech site cnet and he's joining us
from maryland in the u.s very good to
have you with us
tell us about what this all is about i
mean facebook says some users but this
looks like a global outage how
widespread is it
well
it's hard to tell i will say that when
we're talking about facebook more than
half the world's online population is
using it every month so you know a few
users can be a lot of users but this is
this is a signif look these these
outages happen from time to time right
sometimes they are the result of bad
behavior hacks or something other times
it's someone who pushed the wrong button
and this time it seems like it may have
been not a bad thing it may have been
someone pushed the wrong button or some
computer is misconfigured and that'll
get fixed at some point but this has
been going on for over an hour now which
is long yeah
it is long and look these things tend to
be unusual because facebook in
particular really prides itself on
working really well you know over the
last i'd say five ten years we've seen
google apple facebook amazon all of them
have been relatively stable before that
it was pretty it was pretty normal for
the internet to kind of go in and out
and some websites not to work
you can look up the twitter fail whale
if you remember that period of internet
history so you know this stuff did
happen but it is unusual more so now and
so yeah having it out for an hour is
definitely uh noteworthy
and this is coming in a day after a
whistleblower revealed that the company
facebook prioritized profit over public
good
and we know that political pressure has
been building on the company we're not
speculating of course here whether
there's a link between that and what's
happening today but i'm wondering you
know with all this bad publicity right
now for facebook and this political
pressure can can the company withstand
all this bad pressure and bad publicity
what do they have to do to change things
around
yeah i mean look i think that they are
under a really a lot of pressure from
all over the place right not just
their critics and people like me in
silicon valley but also you've got the
regulators in washington all over the
world and look it's very clear that
facebook needs to really reckon with
what they have done
both in terms of actually allowing bad
behavior to continue happening on their
platform and how they haven't been
honest and forthright with you and me
and everybody else about how bad the
situation is and that that is a really
big problem how bad is the situation
i mean it's very clear that uh that
harassment and uh the spread of
disinformation undermining democracy all
these things have been happening on a
wider scale than facebook has told us
about we don't have access to any data
that actually tells us all we have are
little slivers of information right so
it is a big big problem and the company
has shown internally that they know that
right
that's what the whistleblower of course
revealed uh in um
in reports that we we read about
yesterday you know when you see all this
in
you wonder of course
if you know one company facebook owning
multiple major online platforms is a
good idea what can regulators do about
this
yeah i mean look there's been efforts
inside of washington to talk about
whether or not facebook should be forced
to be broken up you may remember that 20
years ago that conversation was
happening around microsoft and the way
that turned out was that even though
microsoft was found to be a monopoly all
the government did was slap it on the
wrist and allow it to continue being
microsoft so i don't know exactly how
far the us government's going to be
willing to go here but i am curious to
see whether this appetite for reigning
in the tech industry will be any
different from what it was a couple of
decades ago
thank you so much for talking to us
about this ian share from cnet joining
us there from maryland thank you for
your time
thank you